to be maybe like 12 before I tell her
yeah this is a great place to get it out
right I know these [__] are
gonna send it to anyways but make sure
you clip this [__] so there's a little
Park where we used to live at about a
year and a half already he got pretty
good at climbing the net that goes off
the side oh yeah you can go down the
slide by himself he's ready for the Army
dude yeah he's really good as the kid
gets better and better you're like
chilling stinks get stronger and
stronger oh okay you know the the pole
where you can slide up and down he goes
up to the pole probably like this this
tall he holds on to the pole I don't
know oh he's probably gonna slide down
he just falls off oh cool
run over there grab him and he didn't
even cry or anything and I'm like did he
break his bones he's paralyzed in the
spine oh babies are strong and resilient
she was like oh how's the park it was
awesome
nobody fell off the pole
he's over here walking like this
I think he's shy now